hello you go against yogurt Eric LeBron
yeah we have played some some games then
the Queens gambit classical I wonder I
don't really remember what he plays let
me try the Tata cover and see what he
does against that no clear memory is he
going for that that wacky long castles
line it would be right up his alley
takes takes long castles yeah it's a
tough line in blitz chess it just leads
to completely wacky positions
objectively it's not very good for white
but we will see it will get it will we
will apple's typical total mayhem
securing the King side here and go for a
counter play next so c5 I just have to
open up everything here as quickly as
possible so cheeks only five or maybe
rook c8 cheranide f6 and 94 maybe yeah
they're already getting close to that
mentioned mayhem sg6 is yeah something
might happen on g6 you can also just go
at five yeah that's certainly possible
h5 yeah definitely okay so I was
thinking maybe 94 just trying to open
the position myself yeah come on it's
it's a it's going to be crazy anyway so
okay here i could also take on c3 i was
thinking of this though I just wanted to
recapture it's probably objectively bad
but what can you do
96 Regev 695 look at four maybe it's bad
but it's not easy not easy i think okay
so he wants to check me queen bee three
yeah not much choice check so over here
now something bad happening it doesn't
look so bad i 95 oh wow okay i can still
go back to back to h aid so where do i
do PF 6
what does he have something stronger
here Knight f6 King edge eh eh eh night
e 6 I don't know it's that's all too bad
okay I cannot play this I don't I don't
think that taking the exchange is such a
big deal position still is reasonably
murky
I think he has to take I'm threatening
group takes you three so maybe I'm not
but I'm close to doing that Oh
interesting move just check him that
this is I have to do this and now the
long diagonal is kind of interesting
here I take t5 here what is he taking
with with the Queen plea checks it
doesn't quite work if I go eat tuned I
ve to guess wiki one no just takes it ok
so Roxy Tula's 95 that was his idea
is 94 it's a pretty pretty annoying
resource okay so that didn't really help
pushing the e porn
think I'm threatening 55 now not quite
sure about this but
it's not easy it's not an easy position
I should be worse but we also may be
losing but still not not so easy to do
she's taking a very long time but it
said some connection issue might be we
just takes that yeah and so i guess i
have to take so it's playing at a very
in somewhat conservative way here k take
him
and now I don't have Quincy for idiotic
very bad what am i doing time morning I
could have could have just chair avoided
this easily very easily black resins
just have to him Quincy FOIA Quincy for
first and then not much happening i
think maybe maybe maybe but ok it was
there was a very tough game um yeah that
line here with non casual it has a
pretty dolly reputation but i don't
really know exactly why I'm to be honest
c5 maybe maybe c5 I don't know I think
this is not particularly bad this kind
of setup maybe I should have played c5
immediately here and i know i mean the
position yes is interesting i'm not not
sure that this is bad for me until it
takes rook c8 and now he went here might
have six and h5 yeah came Knight takes
h5 is this also possibility that that
looks dangerous really a lot
yeah man yeah I'm not sure there's some
something like this i don't i don't
really believe it now again that that is
not working at all yeah maybe I should
take the pawn it's there's nope no clear
we know anything for white I just wanted
to play more active labor yeah yeah I
don't get it then this is so great to be
honest look Fe eight is good for black I
just want to kind of interest it around
here maybe this is not a good idea I
mean I really felt like I couldn't do
something on see to it I mean I cannot
do this he just has this and I'm lost
this makes it to probably very very bad
after this it's just a total mess
can the engine evaluation is equal it
this is strike throwing couple of dice
in the game now your tool doesn't
doesn't work I was still pretty
surprised to hear that and the thing is
what am I supposed to play I cannot go
Quincy forth this as d 7 is coming maybe
I have a hard time yet to prevent that
the other computer also gives white a
clear advantage I felt that with
material equal I shouldn't be so bad but
the issue is the deponent is too strong
may I have no good move him like the
thing I was pretty optimistic here
because I felt okay if I can stop the
corner this is just winning it's just
winning but d7 is a pretty bad threat
and I don't have a clear way to counter
that computer wants to do this now 22
still have this idea in case of rookie
have one but night a4 is supposedly good
for white which is not an easy move to
play what is the point actually Quincy 3
or let's say I go here yeah that means
you three and then this one looks a bit
strange have the night stranded down but
yeah man this is this is just not
working at all yeah it's always very
tough for me in this in this super sharp
positions against him is just very good
in them okay well thanks for watching